BRAD RYDZEWSKI:
All right, thanks.
Thanks everyone for having us.
My name is Brad Rydzewski.
I'm a founder of a start-up
that's called drone.io.
We do continuous integration,
deployment, and dev ops tools.
We're located here
in the Bay Area.
I'm really excited to be
here, especially knowing
the background with
Google Web Toolkit.
We're huge GWT programmers
over the last year.
I think I still have an
HTML5 Nintendo emulator out
on the app store somewhere.
So go check it out, but don't
play with any illegal games
or anything like that.
MATT NORRIS: Hi I'm
Matt Norris, I'm
actually a program manager
at General Electric.
I do software development and
architecture, and basically
my department dabbles in
lots of new technologies,
brings new technologies
into my business,
and I have a background
in graphics and animation.
I'm also very, very
excited to be here.
It's almost as
excited as this guy.
I don't know if I'm as
excited because I can't jump
that high in the air, but as
Seth said, Dart 1.0 is out,
so that's great.
That means you've got a
stable library to play with,
and we're going to actually
show you the benefits right now.
So Brad's going to go into
a demo of a very simple
application that we'll
go through soup to nuts.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Thanks, Matt.
I think one of the
interesting things
to just add on about Dart
1.0, the language is stable,
the API stable, they're
working on performance.
These are all great
things, but a language
is more than just the syntax.
As Seth said, it's an ecosystem.
So if you're going to
be developing in Dart,
you want to know what
technologies are available,
what tools, what frameworks.
And so these are the things
we're going to go to,
and to do that, we wanted to
build an app, soup to nuts,
and go through the code,
client server, database.
And so I'm just going
to click on this,
so we'll jump out,
and prepare to be
amazed by an awesome
URL shortener.
Pretty much just works
as you would expect.
I'm going to type in a URL,
and I'm going to click shorten,
and it's going to shorten it.
And then I'm going to
click it, and it goes.
Of course, the ironic
thing is the shortened URL
was actually I think
longer than Google.com,
but that's not a big deal.
MATT NORRIS: If that's the worst
thing that happens in the demo,
then I think we're doing OK.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Yeah.
So just to describe that, we
did a client-side app in Dart,
we did the server-side
code in Dart,
and we're actually
persisting hashing the URLs
and persisting those in
a Redis key value store,
so that when you visit the
URL, it's pulling the hash out
and sending you need to link.
All right, so
let's jump back in.
And I can already talked
about that, what we'll learn,
but client, server side app.
We're going to
talk about testing,
we're going to talk a little bit
about deploying some language
features, some tools.
A lot of people here
from a Java background,
so I know you'll care
about the tools, things
like continuous
integration, et cetera.
MATT NORRIS: So you'll
notice that on the client,
we're going to start there.
The way that you include Dart
into your web application
is very similar to--
it's very familiar
as to how you
include JavaScript.
So there's a script
to include, you
see the type is actually
application Dart.
And what allows us to use
this in a browser that's
outside of Dartium,
which Seth went over
in terms of
development, is dart.js.
So that's what takes
your Dart code,
compiles it into JS so that
it can be used in any browser.
To dive into the index
itself, each Dart application
really starts off
as two key files.
We've got the HTML
file, and then we've
got your Dart script
that's running.
And in our particular
form, there's
the input, where you
put your long URL.
We've got a button that you
click so that it's actually
calls Dart from the background.
That's where we have
the action wired up.
And we've got a
hidden anchor tag,
that's where we're going to
stuff the hashed short URL when
we're all said and done.
Dart is a little bit
different than JavaScript.
If you'll notice, each
Dart file actually
has a main, which it's not
a huge surprise if you've
come from Java or
any other language,
it's just the way that the
convention that's used.
And in just in this
particular instance,
the only thing we're
really doing here
is we're wiring up the
listener to the button
itself on the HTML file.
Really kind of a
cool thing though
is the simplicity in
which you can do this.
If you're familiar with jQuery,
you'll feel right at home.
Dart uses a query
selector so that you're
able to actually
grab what you need to
and attach the event
listener that way.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: All right, so
we've wired up the onClick.
This is just a quick look
at the onClick function.
Again, if you've
coded in JavaScript
this should look
extremely familiar.
We're creating the HTTP request.
We have the onReady
state changed,
so when we send the request,
we can get a response back.
Of course there's some
more complete code,
this demo is posted,
we just didn't stuff it
all into the slides.
And then when we get
the response back,
we're going to use that to
populate the form calling
this show text method.
And then there's
one thing I wanted
to cover because, as
you're going through Dart,
you're going to see
some new syntax things,
and some people
had some questions,
like what's going on with
this thing right here?
This underscore?
And really, it's just
the listener is invoking
this function on callback,
and it would typically
be passing in
event handler data,
and we're just
going to ignore it,
and so that's what we're
doing with that underscore, is
we just don't really
care about it.
And so you'll see that from
time to time in Dart code
and maybe even
further in this demo.
So as see these types
of things, we'll
try to point out what they mean.
MATT NORRIS: Seth
mentioned this is well.
This is one of the
really cool things
that we found about Dart
was the syntactic sugar.
It takes a lot of
the boilerplate stuff
that you're used to kind of
putting together and having
to piece together
in other languages,
and boils it down so that
you're not using as much,
you're not thinking
through as much,
and string interpolation
is a great example of this.
The thing that I found that
actually most fascinating
was the cascades, so
Seth also covered that.
I'm going to gush a
little bit more about this
because this is where, as
developers, 90% of your time
is spent maintaining
stuff, not writing it.
And anything that you
write is inherently
shared with other people,
you work on teams, and even
yourself.
A few months later after you
write something and go back
to it, you might not quite
remember exactly what it did.
So this is--
anything that you can
do with a language to
make it more readable,
make it more like
prose, is a great thing.
Programming is poetry.
You're all writers, and
this makes your job easier.
It's absolutely
fantastic, and it really
helps in maintaining
things in the future.
So for this particular,
just to explain what's
going on in the
code, the URL short,
the anchor tag
that we're actually
going to update the
attributes when the show text
function is invoked.
And just like in
the code that you
saw before, we're
taking all of the things
that we want to
change about it, we
want to put the
new href in there,
we want to change
its name so that you
see what the actual
short hashed link is.
And we're doing it with
cascade, so it's very, very easy
to read and maintain later.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: All right.
So now what I'd like to do is
just jump back to the demo.
Who would have thought we could
actually demo more with this?
We're going to go
to yahoo.com, and we
generated the hash, and
boom, we didn't redirect.
So what happened?
What broke?
And so let's jump
back into the pitch,
and we can kind of further
analyze what happened here.
Well, we didn't type the
HTTP, we just typed the www,
and it turns out
when the server tried
to do the redirect without the
HTTP, it wasn't able to do so.
And those are kind of
like the mundane details
that as developers
sometimes we forget about.
And so we thought
that was a nice segue
into the next topic, which
is going to be unit tests.
MATT NORRIS: So every time
you kind of come across one
of these things that might not
cross your mind earlier when
you develop something, every
time somebody finds a bug,
you want to write that
unit test so that you
make sure you have
coverage going forward.
This is starting
from the client side.
We're going to take a look at
how to implement this in Dart.
The first thing you do is import
the unit test library, which
is baked into-- is
thought of from the very
first implementation--
baked into Dart itself,
so it's really great.
You also will pull in an
HTML-enhanced configuration,
which I'll show you what
the output is in a second,
but basically when you're
doing your development workflow
in Dartium, it's
a simple command
to actually format the
results of the unit tests
and, in a nice way,
in the browser.
And finally, the meat of
this is the test itself.
So what we said when somebody
came in with a bug report
and said hey, I tried to put
in this URL and it didn't work.
We say, OK, it's because
we forgot the protocol.
We now write a couple
of tests to make sure
that we have that
coverage going forward.
We check that it's a
valid URL, is working,
and that we get everything--
stuff the protocol--
and if people do
not include that.
So when you run the
test itself, this
is the output that you get.
It shows you that all
your tests have passed.
You're green, so
you're good to go.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI:
Actually one more thing
that I wanted to just bring up
because GWT came up earlier,
and we've got a lot
of Java developers.
I remember, one thing
I love about this,
is that I can run my test
directly against a real DOM.
If you're programming
in GWT before,
maybe you remember Ray Ryan's
talk on model view presenter,
and you had to actually
mock your entire UI.
And so, I think this is awesome
that when I write my unit
tests against my web page,
I get hit an actual real DOM
and I don't have to write all
that extra boilerplate mocking
code.
MATT NORRIS: So like Brad
said, this is fantastic,
and it's really great to see
everything kind of included
in Dartium and the
Dart editor itself,
it's very nice workflow.
You don't have to jump to
a lot of different places,
everything's contained.
But there's going
to be points in time
when you want to do things,
you want to script them out,
you want to do them faster.
You're not going
to do them manually
by control running something.
And so that's what brings us
into the next topic, which
is headless browser testing.
And this is really done-- Dart
provides a very nice utility
to take care of this.
It's a headless browser with
full DOM, like Brad said,
and it's faster than
running something
like HTTP unit and Selenium.
So anything that we
can do with a browser,
we can do in the
headless browser.
So we use content shell,
which is the tool itself.
And the way that
we do this is we
call this with an argument
of Dump-render-tree.
And you'll see that the
file that it's pointing to
is actually the
same that we invoked
that you saw in
the previous slide
within the browser itself.
And when we call that, we
see that same content too.
All our tests passed,
so we're good to go.
But it's happening
on the command line,
so it can be done much quicker
and built into our build steps
later on.
AUDIENCE: So what would
happen with negative test?
Let's say you had
a faulty web page.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: So you
mean in terms of you
want to test errors,
like you expect errors?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Negative testing.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI:
So yeah, I think--
Do we have an example
of that in here?
MATT NORRIS: I don't think
we have an example of it,
but it's something
that you could do.
It just all depends on how
you structure your tests.
So there's more code
behind the scenes.
It's actually something
that we didn't prepare
for this particular application,
but we can definitely
add that into the GitHub
projects and show as an example
if that's something
you'd like to see.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Yeah, I'm sure
there are plenty of examples,
and maybe Seth can
answer that one.
When we're done, he
can talk to that.
Because I know some of
the Dart team there,
they're running
hundreds of these types
of tests and analyzing
[? outputs, ?]
so I'm sure they're doing
those types of tests.
But basically anything you
can do from a Dart unit test,
you're running in headless mode.
So if you're familiar with
like a PhantomJS or something
like that, it's that for Dart,
maybe a little more primitive,
but hopefully it will
evolve over time.
So now I want to talk
the server piece.
Seth mentioned, Dart has HTTP,
TCP, all this stuff built in.
Of course we could talk
about the low level
handlers, the request
handlers and stuff,
but I don't program like that.
That reminds me of
1999 Java servlets.
I typically like to
use a web framework.
It maked me more productive.
I don't have to handle parsing
URL paths and stuff like that.
And so we're just going
to jump straight to it.
This is a framework.
It's called start.dart.
It rhymes.
If you're familiar
with Express for node,
if you're familiar with Sinatra
for Ruby, Rat Pack for Groovy,
Spark for Java, there's
tons of frameworks
like this that make
it really easy to deal
with URL routing
and stuff like that.
And so what we're doing here
is we're invoking start.
What we see is this
public web, that is,
we're pointing it
to the server where
we're serving our static
content out of our CSS
files, our Dart script.
And then this is
where we're declaring
that we want to
handle this route,
so the code where you have
the dot-dot-dot, that will get
invoked any time we do a
post to that route, which
is, of course,
important because we're
going to be posting
a URL to this route
in order to get back a hash.
And so, let's kind
of quickly look
at what we would fill this with.
It should be pretty
straightforward.
We're getting the
URL from the request,
we're hashing it
using a simple SHA
hash built into the
Dart library, awesome.
Dart has a standard library,
has all this great stuff in it,
so I didn't have to write
a SHA hashing algorithm
or anything like that, I was
able to just take it right out
of the library.
And then we're using
a Redis client.
Obviously, I don't show
how you start it up here.
I didn't think
that was necessary.
But we're doing
something simple.
We're setting the hash as the
key, the URL as the value,
And of course, this
is asynchronous,
and so, as Seth
mentioned, this is
where futures come into play.
And so we're saying
when this is done,
we're going to invoke
this function here,
and we're going to say
respond with the hash.
And so, Seth kind
of touched on it,
but it's kind of nice to be
able to use this future syntax,
especially when you get
multiple of these thens,
you avoid that callback
hell, so we really
like that as we are programming.
And actually, this is
a simplified version,
we have an over
engineered hashing one
that uses much more thens
in the actual GitHub repo.
So, we've persisted to Redis,
we've persisted to the hash,
and now we need the
redirect function,
so when someone visits
the shortened URL,
we're going to look it up
just simply with Redis.git,
we're going to get the hash.
Again, this is asynchronous,
so we're using a future.
We're getting the value,
and we're redirecting.
So again, very, very simple
readable code in Dart.
We love it.
MATT NORRIS: So just like
we tested the client,
we're going to test
the server as well.
And what's great about
running the same code
on the server and the
client, is that things
are going to feel very familiar.
So like we did before, we're
going to pull in the unit test
library and we're going to
do something a little bit
different because we're not
going to be testing the HTML,
we're actually going to
use the virtual machine
in this instance.
And to test that the
hash is working properly,
we first check to see that
it's just returning something.
We just want to make
sure that it's not null.
And then we know what the
specific hash will be.
It's a simple hash,
so we're going
to test for that specific hash.
And to run it, all you do is
in the command line, Dart,
whatever your test
file's name is,
and you can see whether
it passes or fails.
And in this case, it passes.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: All right.
Seth touched on this,
so we don't have a lot
to say about it because it's
so simple deployment, Heroku.
It's a great option.
This is literally
what it took for us
to get this running on Heroku.
Heroku create.
Seth mentioned the
second command,
we give it a URL to what
they call a buildpack, which
is essentially
instructions to create
a virtual machine on the fly.
Very simple.
Heroku add-ons, we add
a Redis data store,
and within seconds we
had a Redis database,
and then we just get push.
And so it's a great
way if you're just
getting started with Dart, and
you're building a cool app,
and you want to
show it to people,
definitely try out Heroku.
If you Google the
Dart buildpack,
there's instructions for
a little more in-depth
for getting this all working.
MATT NORRIS: Just a
question to everybody,
does anybody know about
how many browser and OS
combinations there
are out there?
[LAUGHTER]
A million.
I think that's pretty close.
Another guess here.
AUDIENCE: Are you counting
Linux as one or many?
MATT NORRIS: Let's
go with many, many.
As many permutations
as possible.
So--
AUDIENCE: Does that
include different versions?
MATT NORRIS: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Does that
include different versions?
MATT NORRIS: It includes
different versions too.
Lots.
So you see this is quickly
spiraling out of control.
There's at least over 200
different combinations of,
I'll say the modern ones,
so not every single one.
I was just trying to get
as many numbers as I could.
But--
AUDIENCE: Let's say 2002 or
2004 when Web 2.0 was around,
[INAUDIBLE] a while,
though, right?
MATT NORRIS: Yeah, yeah.
There is some cut-off date,
so-- but for the modern ones,
let's say that it's
over 200 about,
approximately, the
different combinations.
And so when we're
creating web applications,
are all of us going
out and testing
all those combinations
ourselves manually?
Probably not.
So that brings us
to our next segment,
which is cross browser testing.
Selenium probably everybody's
pretty familiar with.
You know, Selenium IDE,
you can record tests
within your browser, Selenium
server, you run those tests.
We're actually--
Dart's got capabilities
where you can actually do
the scripting for the test
within Dart.
So again, you're keeping all
of your code in one place
and using the same language.
And here we just
picked that one sample,
but basically we're creating
the WebDriver here in Selenium,
and we're saying, I want to
test on an Android browser.
Picture multiple
iterations of this,
you've got Firefox, Chrome,
et cetera, everything
that you could stuff in,
add as many as you need to.
So that's setting up.
The actual test itself
is, what we're doing,
we're basically finding, again,
we're finding an element,
we're doing something
to that element.
And what's neat is
we're actually back
to the future syntax
that we saw earlier.
So, again, this is a
simplified version,
but we're basically
nesting-- we're
able to stagger a whole
lot of asynchronous calls
to actually achieve the
testing that we want.
And right in the middle
of everything, smack dab
in the middle of
everything, we can actually
throw in an expectation.
So that's your test right there.
So you can have multiple
ones of these chained off
of each other, and it's just
a nice way to actually, again,
format this, put it in
a very readable format,
and execute a lot
of different tests
and a lot of different
expectations.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: So yes, Selenium
directly in Dart is awesome.
As Matt mentioned, there's
200-plus combinations.
And maybe some of you
guys have seen this,
it's called Sauce Labs.
I think it's actually by
a bunch of ex-Google guys
that ran their internal
testing, but it's
a web service that
works with Selenium
that lets you test tons
of different permutations.
So once you have the Selenium
code working locally,
you just point it directly
at the Sauce Lab servers,
and in parallel,
they're going to test
against a bunch of
different browsers.
And so we actually took
the test, I have it here,
and we ran it against Firefox.
And what's pretty cool is when
you're running in Sauce Labs,
they actually will
record your entire set,
run your tests,
show you the output,
any types of error messages.
And it's really a
boring video, it's just
showing what we showed you
like two times already,
but you can see it's running
with the Dart library
and it's running on
the Sauce Labs engine.
And so this is
something that you
can start using
today to test in all
these different
permutations and scenarios.
The other thing that
I wanted to show,
just because it was
so easy, I decided
I wanted to test our
app in Android Why not?
I just had to change
like literally one
parameter in Sauce, and
I'm testing it in Android.
And this actually ended up
being pretty fascinating,
and it kind of goes to
Seth's earlier point
is that we should be
testing everything on mobile
and using the viewport.
And I think this will become
very clear when I show you
what we found when we
ran this on Android.
So we're running it on
Android, and I'm not
going to show the
video, I'll just
show some of the screen shots.
We instruct Selenium to click
on the field and add the text.
And what does it immediately do?
It zooms in all big, and I
can't see any of the page now,
I can't even see the button.
And Selenium is able to
actually put in the URL,
so that was scripted correctly.
But then we tell Selenium
to click the button,
and Selenium fails.
Selenium says, we
can't fix it-- let
me read this-- this web
element is not visible
and may not be clicked.
And so that's actually
kind of awesome,
because normally when I'm
using a tool like Selenium,
I'm thinking it's going to find
bugs, like glitches in code,
but this actually kind
of like a UX error.
So again, just kind of
a nice byproduct of this
is being able to test on
mobile, see how your app looks.
So maybe you had Android,
but you don't iPhone,
or you have iPhone, but
you don't have an iPad.
This does all
these permutations,
it's free for open
source projects.
And there are paid
plans, and it's probably
cheaper than hosting all
the infrastructure yourself.
So definitely
highly recommended.
MATT NORRIS: I think
we had a question--
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Oh.
MATT NORRIS: Out
in the audience.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I was just
curious, with Sauce Labs,
I saw it was
testing local hosts?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does part
of the test for Sauce
tells you, tells it,
how to run the server?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: So the way
Sauce Labs works, it actually
is like a bundled version
of Selenium that proxies.
So what happens,
actually almost exactly
like what you were
showing with the DevTools,
I'm running the app
locally, and Sauce Labs
is providing a
local server that's
proxying all the
traffic to their servers
in their environment, so very
similar to what you demoed.
Was there another question?
OK.
Jumping back into the pitch.
So, the kind of last technology
we wanted to touch on
was continuous integration.
Obviously we built our app,
we're running our tests.
It would be great to do that
automatically, especially
in a team setting, if we
have multiple collaborators,
et cetera.
And so back in October
2011 when Dart launched,
my company, drone.io,
started supporting Dart
as a language for
continuous integration.
And so a lot of
the Dart projects
are doing continuous
integration on drone.io.
It supports other
languages as well.
So that's what I wanted
to show to you today.
So we're going to go
ahead and click on-- maybe
not-- so actually I
have it up right here.
So this is drone.io-- yeah,
all right, it's showing up.
It's a continuous
integration server.
If you're familiar with Jenkins,
similar type of concept.
Some interesting
things with drone.io.
It's completely hosted
like Sauce Labs.
You don't have to
set it up yourself,
you don't have to
manage your own servers.
You can just log into the
website and set up an account.
But that's actually not
what I'm showing you today.
I'm actually showing
you the open source
version of drone.io.
So this is actually
something you'll
be able to download and
run on your own servers.
If you're running
Jenkins today, this
would be an alternate solution.
So we actually haven't
showed this yet,
and it's not scheduled
to come out next week.
But I was really
excited to show it,
and I've been waiting
to show this to people,
so-- bear with me because it's
not quite production ready yet,
so fingers crossed
to the demo gods
that Seth was
praying to earlier.
So we're going to
go in and we're
going to set up our
repository from GitHub.
So I'm just going to go
ahead and type that in.
I think that's
what it was called.
All right, so just that
simple, we added the project,
it actually linked it to
GitHub, it added a key,
it set up hooks that
will automatically
trigger a build every time a
developer pushes a code change.
So very simple to get
up and running with CI,
especially if you're kind
of used to downloading,
installing Jenkins,
installing software,
all that kind of stuff.
So let me just kind of
jump back into the pitch
because I think the one
thing we want to show
is how do we set up a build.
How do we instruct it
our build commands,
how do we tell it to compile
or run our Dart code,
run our Dart tests.
And we do that with a
simple YAML configuration
file that you'll check into
the root of your repository.
And this has some
benefits in the sense
you could build
branches differently.
So what does this YAML file do?
It sits in the root
of your repository.
The first thing we're
saying is the image,
we want to use a Dart image.
The cool thing about Drone
is it runs all your builds
inside a virtual
machine, and it downloads
those virtual machines from a
centralized repository using
a technology called Docker.
So you actually don't ever have
to install your own software
or configure your own
build environments.
We have pre-built
virtual machines, so
Dart, JAVA for the Java
developers out there,
I think 14 different languages
and multiple versions.
The second piece we're
just instructing it,
what are the build
commands we want it to run?
And then we can optionally
even deploy to Heroku
at the end of the
build automatically,
to get that continuous
delivery flow going.
And so-- let's see how do
we want to do this-- just
to jump back in and show
you how this would work.
This is my GitHub
repository, and we're
going to make a
change to this file
to just trigger a
build in real time.
It should email me.
That's my email address, so
feel free to send me a note
if you ever want to say hi.
And we're going to
make the change.
And we're notified via
WebSocket new build running.
I'm going to go
ahead and click that.
And then we can actually see
the build output streaming live
in real time, so it's going
to run our build test.
So this is a technology
that is available today
online for if you're
developing open source
projects, open source Dart.
Feel free to use this to
automate your unit tests,
automate your deployments.
And if you're interested when we
have this available next week,
definitely check it out as
the open source project.
MATT NORRIS: Just a
comment on the benefit
of continuous integration,
it's really great
to have a tool like
Drone where you
don't have to think about
running things all the time.
Essentially, you just want
to be as lazy as possible.
You don't want to worry about
having to run any tests.
You don't want to have to
worry about certain checks.
As a developer, you
want to do cool stuff,
you don't want to be bogged
down in the boilerplate.
And getting on board with
automated testing, automated
builds, automated
deployment is really, really
going to help you
out, and you can just
discover new things, which
is what we like to do.
So just to recap, what
have we learned today?
We built an entire
Dart application, so
client and server.
We saw that the same code's
used on both client and server.
We persisted something
to a database,
so we went round trip.
We tested things with
various testing tools.
We saw whether it's through
HTML or the command line,
and we actually deployed it.
So we deployed something, and it
was live, it's out in the world
there.
And as we were
doing so, we touched
on a few of the language
features of Dart
and some additional tools that
can help you with the workflow.
Again, wrapping up with
that continuous integration
and really showing
how that could really
ease your workflow
as a developer.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: So, I think in
conclusion, Dart is awesome,
Dart has an awesome
ecosystem, and it's still
a very young language.
And hopefully some
of these tools,
if you're coming from a
different background, Java
or whatever, you'll feel
a little more at home,
and they'll help you be
a little more productive.
So what should you do?
Try Dart, test things,
use tools, and deploy.
So thank you, everyone, and we'd
love to take some questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So, the tool you
demonstrated for drone.io,
was that a new tool
that is [INAUDIBLE]?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Yes, so--- When
AUDIENCE: When about
might it be out,
and what is it-- who
does it serve, exactly?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Yeah, so
website drone.io that is live,
it's been live for a
year, and I think of it
as like a hosted Jenkins
for anyone to use.
But what I demoed is
the open source addition
that you can download,
install, and run directly
on your own servers,
and you should see that
literally any time in
the next couple days.
I was hoping it would
be ready for today,
but you know how things go.
It's targeted at people
who want to use Jenkins.
Maybe you want to do CI, but
you want it on your own servers.
AUDIENCE: And
that's called what?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: It's called
Drone, drone.io is the website.
And so yes, sometime next
week, we'll be announcing it.
We usually announce that
stuff on Twitter or whatever,
so if it's something
you're interested in,
find us on Twitter as
we're making announcements.
We're also actually giving a
talk related to it, Dart Plus
Docker Virtualization
and Drone on Thursday
at Rackspace in
downtown San Francisco.
So if you're in that area,
you should definitely
come to that talk as well.
And Seth will be there,
but not speaking,
but you could probably
ask him questions
that you didn't get ask
here, there if you want.
MATT NORRIS: No pressure, Seth.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Yeah.
Any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
memory issues [INAUDIBLE]
virtual machine?
I've been using those
for almonst a year
now and finding some
performance and memory issues.
This one is new to
me, so [INAUDIBLE]
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: I
think that's probably
a question for Seth's expertise.
I'm going to say Dart is awesome
and has no memory issues,
but I'm going to let
Seth reinforce that fact.
SETH LADD: No, we don't
have memory leaks,
so that was easy to answer.
No, one distinction
of course, I don't
know what libraries
you're using,
et cetera, but one thing that we
take very seriously on the Dart
project is tool ability.
And so we've been
working on this project
called Observatory, which
is actually a Polymer app.
You connect directly
to the virtual machine
and you get to inspect
it in real time.
And we're adding
more and more things
to it, things like what are
my isolates doing right now,
what's a heat profile
going on right now,
what's a CPU profile
going on right now.
So, I don't know every
time people have bugs,
but we hope to
give you the tools
to go in and find the
problem and fix the problem.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Any
other questions?
Or any others for Seth
before he sits back down?
MATT NORRIS: Thank you again.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI:
Thanks, everyone.